nobinome ont chacun 20 noyau le gagnant
sera celui qui arrivera en crachant à
mettre le plus de noyau dans le bol de
son partenaire simple basique comme
dirait l'autre et c'est l'équipe verte
qui démarre son lancé de 20 noyaux alors
combien arriverons dans le récipient
allez c'est parti c'est parti
qui va rester qui va partir le dossier
brûlant au sommet de l'exécutif à
quelques jours du remaniement se tenait
hier le dernier dîner à l'Élysée avant
la pose estivale à table des ministres
qui ne savent pas le sort qui leur sera
réservé Emmanuel Macron leur a déclaré
j'ai été à votre place et je sais que
ces moments ne sont jamais agréables il
faut prendre beaucoup de distance
la forêt là
après c'est lui qui a merdé aussi c'est
lui qui nous emmené mais il nous a amené
alors là pour le coup il nous a amenés
dans son délire les loyaux on n'est pas
bien
c'est pas un peu bizarre
mais pourquoi ce serait bizarre mais
c'est quand même bizarre il y a un
remaniement dans les prochains jours il
y a des ministres qui vont quitter le
gouvernement ça fait une drôle
d'ambiance quand même la vie ne s'arrête
pas qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je
vous dise moi je n'ai vu que des gens
charmants qui étaient heureux de d'être
ensemble pour un moment de convivialité
[Musique]
de fragile que quelqu'un de très fort tu
vas je te relais parce que les costauds
dans ce jeu sont éliminés c'est pas tous
les jours
les jours comme ça c'est un peu
compliqué la vie de ministre moi je veux
pas me plaindre j'ai choisi d'y être
mais voilà ça fait du bien de se
retrouver et puis d'évoquer un peu des
sujets
[Musique]
plus plus léger peut-être un instant
voilà un instant de répit doit avouer
que je croyais avoir vu pas mal
à 40 50 politiques mais j'étais loin de
tout connaître encore de la nature
humaine on va écouter Jordan Bardella
c'est vrai que le rassemblement national
a été l'un des premiers partis à dire
tout comme les républicain d'ailleurs
celui qui casse celui qui paye il pille
celui qui casse il paye mais c'était pas
faux non ce jour-là Adam commerçant du
quartier vend à quelques jeunes de quoi
faire des grillades ce qu'il ne sait pas
c'est qu'elle serviront lors de cette
fête illégale à laquelle il a fini par
se rendre et puis tu sens bien ils sont
bien amusés ce bien éclater ils ont dit
ils ont mangé pour aussi ce qui compte
parce que c'est vrai que le quartier
j'ai l'abandonné avant de cuire vos
chipolatas au barbecue
il est conseillé de les piquer avec une
fourchette pour qu'elle reste tant
tiens la vraie c'est faux
je le fais mais pendant là
les familles se réjouissent de cette
fête foraine inattendue qu'il pense
organiser par la mairie mais derrière ce
sont bien des dealers mon j ma grille et
membre du collectif qui a dénoncé cette
action c'est pareil ils étaient dans la
confusion parce qu'ils ont participé à
quelque chose ils étaient pas volontaire
au départ mais comme ils ont dit
certains aussi ben écoutez il y en a qui
ont pensé à nous ils ont pensé au
quartier abandonné défavorisé ils ont
organisé quelque chose pour les enfants
et nous nous souhaitons que les aides
sociales et les allocations familiales
aux parents de mineurs récidiviste soit
supprimés soit retirés je pense que
c'est un principe non seulement de bon
sens mais un principe de justice les
casseurs doivent payer il faut appliquer
le principe du casseur payeur tu casses
tu payes et si tu ne peux pas payer
c'est tes parents qui payent
oh mais il y a il y a la famille entière
ah là là là là ah ça me donne la chair
de poule depuis Noël je pars mais j'ai
jamais vu ça de ma vie
ce groupe de jeunes a été surpris de
nuit par le gardien du Mont Valérien
alors qu'ils utilisaient la flamme comme
un grill ils avaient jeté une bouteille
de soda et des détritus dans le brûloir
en bronze pour y faire griller des
chamallows l'employé a immédiatement
alerté la police qui est venu
interpeller les six suspects peu après
minuit le Mont Valérien c'est le
principal lieu d'exécution des
résistants et des otages par l'armée
allemande pendant la Seconde Guerre
mondiale plus d'un millier de personnes
y ont été fusillés ce lieu est devenu en
1960 un monument colossal franchir un
mur d'épaisse fumerolles se glisser
entre les tentacules de magma projeté
vers le ciel avec agilité ce drone
esquive plusieurs séries d'explosion
dans un air vibrant de chaleur
l'appareil vient raser la coulée de la
vincandescente
deux ans qu'alexie téléma qu'attendait
de capturer ce spectacle hypnotisant à
l'éveil de ce volcan islandais il y a 10
jours regardez ce fossile
remarquablement préservé il s'agit d'un
petit mammifère voyez sur la gauche
plantant ses crocs dans les côtes d'un
dinosaure faisant trois fois sa taille
la scène réelle reproduite ici en
décembre a été figé en pleine action
dans la cendre d'une éruption volcanique
il y a 125 millions d'années preuve pour
les scientifiques qu'il existait à
l'époque des petits mammifères capables
d'attaquer un dinosaure adulte fasciné
par les volcans depuis l'enfance Alexis
téléma qui avait déjà tenté à deux
reprises d'assister à une éruption
volcanique comme ici en février 2022 où
il est arrivé trop tard
il y a quelques jours il accompli son
rêve après 800 ans de sommeil c'est la
troisième fois en deux ans qu'un volcan
se réveille dans la région au fait
l'Argentine c'est où exactement
l'argentique je crois c'est l'Afrique du
Sud l'Argentine c'est au Brésil bon là
Pierre Olivier les filles se noient
pouvez-vous surfer leur secours et
l'Argentine c'est en Amérique du Sud il
y a le Chili c'est vraiment à l'aide du
Chili presque pareil
en continent près cette ville elle a
traversé beaucoup de tourmentes beaucoup
de soucis on les a toujours surmontés
nous allons de nouveau les surmonter
voilà mais au-delà de surmonter ces
tourments comment vous les expliquez
est-ce que aujourd'hui il y a une
violence plus importante c'est ça qu'on
veut aussi comprendre même si il est dur
de faire un diagnostic à chaud peut-être
j'essaye de vous expliquer que
l'histoire remonte à loin c'est une
histoire qui avait de 30 ans nous avons
un hôpital ici c'est le seul dans le
nord de la Meurthe-et-Moselle nous
n'avons plus de d'infirmières on les
recrute au Liban quels sont vos doutes
genre c'est vous permettre
je viens de parler un petit peu je peux
faire reprendre mon souffle je voterai
comme je le sentirai dans ma venue
on a plus de médecins je suis une ville
de 10000 habitants nous avons plus un
médecin généraliste
je suis enseignant de métier bientôt à
la retraite au 1er septembre après 46
années de bonnes loyers services on
manque d'enseignants il y a plus de
remplacement dans les écoles la plus de
remplacement dans les écoles nous avons
un hôtel de police agglomérations les
situer sur le territoire de la commune
une ville très structurée il manque 30%
de policiers dans cet hôtel de police
nous avons une poste elle est fermée
depuis un an et demi sur un quartier de
4000 habitants je vois le social énorme
quelle phrase commençant par et bien
constitue Nicolas et bien danser
maintenant mais oui bravo
[Musique]